[Musique]
c'est très beau gosse les lunettes
j'aimerais voir ses bouquets debout
alors pas du tout pour autant les bras
si mes chattes de même pas non mais
c'est un goleador très très beau je
voulais mais tu ne fais comme vous sans
un truc je voulais vous dire quoi pour
battre comme ça après direct
oui j'ai apporté tous là pour je suis
très pur shabbat là le pain est toujours
équipée qui l'a révélé si vous voulez
manger je l'adoré c'est comme ça nous
regarde ta mère oui bon là c'est vrai
qu'en mai
vous êtes d'ailleurs josiane non pas
josiane comment s'appelle caroline ali
mais ma mère très bon délire assez
pauvre des fous je peux vous retrouver
une photo de la mère elle est très bonne
en plus à travers la thur à oui je sais
pas la tunisienne qu'on croit genre
hémophilie ces machins c'est pas ça très
beau dire que ma mère allait comme ça
[Rires]
fait une heure à mai soit il ya beaucoup
de ces surcoûts cyril parce que j'ai
fait un peu le malin cette semaine donc
du coup j'ai ramené plein de dossiers
sur vous et on va rigoler cyril puisque
j'ai ramené toutes les séquences que les
téléspectateurs ont manqué et j'ai réuni
tout ça dans une seule séquence comme
chaque semaine ses 50 goal inside in the
life prix salue les loups bienvenue dans
sa coach hugo inside tpm paix on
commence tout de suite avec cyril qui
est capable de parler à son producteur
et débriefer en même temps un magnéto
qui n'a toujours pas vu alors tu as fait
ton calcul ou pas
et tm est un jennifer pas possible pas
si ma fille c'est 44
ce pape aussi frère tt tt tt
c'est assez incroyable c'est incroyable
alors est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
ça cette semaine bernard montiel cette
ambiance et sur un artiste qu'on connaît
tous très ce no x et x ray
c'est une semaine avant de continuer
avec un peu de shakespeare ça fait pas
de mal être drôle ou pas drôles de
questions civiles
est-ce que je peux être encore drôle
j'ai eu mon physique mais ses problèmes
non non ouais tu beaucoup trop beau
gosse cependant pas de guérir
non mais là là là franchement ça mais
c'est à dire que c'est que tu veux pas
créer de faux choix dire qu'on est là je
choisis la bogossitude est ce un péché
on continue avec tiffany qui est prête
pour la prochaine saison de devos
visiblement bernard montiel a pris un
peu trop soleil dans les yeux d'alain
chant précédente et de grenelle à paris
cette version filmée postés sur les
réseaux sociaux qui a les limons choqué
l'opinion extrêmement cette semaine le
mot de la fin
il est vraiment à la casse les couilles
retrouver l'ambiance on allait à la
semaine prochaine dans 50 secondes
inside de pépé
[Applaudissements]
ou alors vous la chanson on se calme on
va pas revenir là dessus mais j'ai vu à
aller aux jo de moscou
oui cyril ce matin france 2 recevait un
invité politique nicolas dupont aignan
je vous suis fière bizarrement ils
étaient là hier la wii alors je vais pas
vous mentir et j'ai regardé les deux
interviews pour comparer au revoir à si
c'était les mêmes questions qui étaient
posées et c'était deux salles deux
ambiances par me retourne et on va voir
bonjour nicolas dupont aignan bonjour si
nicolas dupont aignan d'être avec nous
des personnes
est ce que vous pouvez dire
qu'aujourd'hui la france fait pire que
ses voisins immédiats en tout cas madame
merkel madame merkel langue la langue
est là elle a envoyé
l'europe est complètement démunis est
complètement irresponsable
pourquoi parce que l'europe était dans
une idéologie sans frontiérisme on
rentre c'est le c'est pas possible
2e 3 est à dire celle d'awad demander
s'il ne serait pas nécessaire d'en
arriver une petite à la destitution des
manuels macro monsieur fisher qui dit à
monsieur sur rtl il y aura un vote de
consultation probablement la semaine
prochaine si le président macron annonce
un nouveau confinement ce week-end
bitume fausse des fournisseurs comme des
cons là tu te fais bouffer ici
il ya une autre voie possible je la
propose depuis des mois les patients
solvac ça il a peur des piqûres cela
d'alcool est ce que c'est pour vous je
vous cite la perspective d'un nouvel
enfermement vrai que j'ai mis conclut et
qui nous disent qu'il a pensé de ce tout
ce qu'a dit nicolas dupont aignan
racheter va vous défoncer sur le
confinement pas ce qui se passe en gras
juste pour reprendre votre mot le testan
al raoudha canal maintenant mais non il
ya plus efficace l'alzheimer mon médecin
a tranché je t'aime bien et c'est pas
fini il dans sa dernière mais oui
d'abord pour bernard montiel barma
montiel on le surnomme souvent la miss
des stars exact bernard montiel
c'est l'homme qui tous mais qui connaît
tout le monde mais que personne ne
connaît d'ici là ami avec autant de
monde c'est qu'au fond il doit être
sympa pas bien sûr mais il est sympa
bernard aux acheteurs d'or tu peux pas
savoir
on l'a d'or bernard exception l'adorent
mais je crois que le strass et les
paillettes
laurent dufaux ça l'a rendu fou les dix
ans on l adore mes dix ans comme a dit
syrie de la semaine dernière à son
invité vous prenez pour qui
vous faites quoi pourquoi vous êtes là
mais bon ils nous prennent pour qui il
beach sur tous ses collègues
regardez tarbah
et delphine cette semaine mais bon
oui je sais combien 7 8 ans annoncé trop
gentil
[Musique]
gentil toit des mois
et
j'espère moi de résister mais je te mets
cette nuit parce que je trouve très
sympathique n'entend chronique j'ai peur
de personne
merci mon siège et du coup de tabac ça
passe à l'est daniel manitoba encore 2
oui j'en ai encore de abassi genre
avantage sur tiffany sur vous il garde
le meilleur pour la fin bien sûr
tiffany il ya dans la suite tout [ __ ]
de ma gueule là je m'adresse à tiffany
bons voisins il ya deux semaines
benjamin castaldi avait un petit
business de parfum oui quand on n'est
pas profiter parce que c'est une arnaque
sa peine arnaque vous auriez peut-être
dû lui acheter un petit parfum parce que
si on en croit vos collègues alors c'est
pas moi qui le dit ce sont vos collègues
ça sent pas la rose
[Musique]
c'est pas bien j'ai vraiment que les
choses finissent à akwa l'honneur sans
le beurre en fait le beurre accusé ce
week end une friteuse qui se baladent
demande jamais n'importe quoi
fini le choc et qui a reçu toutes les
vaches c'est pas faux tout et font
défaut benjamin annonce foot fanni je la
connais depuis 15 ans mercy série l'a
jamais shooté j'aurai toujours à
distance voilà les ont emmenés avec vous
s'il vous à la maison qui nous regarde
et je suis sûr que vous dites
cyril il a beau être un petit fou fou un
petit boute-en-train pendant les
magnétos il doit quand même se
concentrer pour suivent bien les débats
en 1 8 oui il ya les [ __ ] en l'air ma
carrière une indique j'en ai donc tout
alors pourquoi les magnétos série l'on
croit qu'il est sérieux mais en fait
vous allez voir et ben il est aussi
agitée qu'à l'antenne voire plus
[Musique]
le roi lui a demandé comment il
s'appelle d'ailleurs le gall une
rencontre qui s'annonce et j'appelle
sylvester je suis heureux de vous
retrouver
depuis cette cité royale de love love
s'était tu habites alors j'ai jamais
écouté prend sa terre de ma vie la
france a peur d'air france mais le
public qui remporte semaines des appels
on peut même pas la racheter 10 de
raconter c'est mon assez médiocre c'est
horrible mais pas car j'ai pas car si
ces figures bancaire et bien d'argent
sur la [ __ ] les étoiles remplir j'ai
ma troisième étoile au ski je vous
emmerde je vais m'en chamois d'or moi
j'ai fermé ma gueule
de sympathiques
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]